the ending to this crafty little show is
a bit controversial among fans
at least each character got their own
individual send-off
here are the most important how i met
your mother character endings
ranked from worst to best as how i met
your mother's resident
lithario barney stinson who's always
clad in a crisp suit and will stop at
nothing to bed
every woman in new york seems like he'll
never change his wild ways
however as the show progresses barney
who seems the least likely of anyone to
settle down
realizes he's in love with robin to
ted's great shame the feeling is
shockingly mutual after several seasons
of tumultuous on-again off-again
relationships the two
finally tied the knot and their wedding
weekend becomes the sole focus of how i
met your mother's ninth
and final season in the series finale
barney goes through a ton of difficult
changes and neither the character nor
the audience is really given any time to
process them
after three difficult years of marriage
he and robin apparently get divorced
robin returns to her career and barney
returns to his old ways
until something completely unexpected
happens he gets a girl
pregnant and becomes the father of a
daughter you
are the love of my life suddenly
barney becomes a judgmental [ __ ]
yelling at women in bars about what
their fathers might think and leaning
into the overprotective
dad vibe with the zeal of a convert
barney turns out to be a layered complex
character
but his ending is oversimplified at best
and flat out
offensive at worst after watching ted
spend nearly the entirety of how i met
your mother
searching for the mother in the title
expectations were high
and ultimately they were met in full by
kristen miliotti's sweet pitch perfect
portrayal of tracy mcconnell
she meets ted as they argue over an
umbrella they've both owned on a rainy
train platform
throughout the final season we get small
glimpses into ted and tracy's
relationship
we also finally learn about tracy a
process of viewer education that
culminates in the standout 9th season
episode
how your mother met me after the show
laid the groundwork of their
relationship for the entire ninth season
fans were enraged when during the series
finale
tracy dies of an unnamed illness and ted
moves on
the entire series's framing device is
revealed to be a guilty ted telling his
teenage children about their dead mother
yikes thanks to the speed of the
finale's overstuffed epilogue
ted's entire life with tracy and her
untimely death happens in a matter of
minutes
providing a pretty unfair ending to the
show's eminently lovable title character
on the surface it seems like robin has
one of the best endings in
all of how i met your mother when you
look closer however you can see the
obvious flaws
after her divorce from barney robin
becomes a famous international
journalist
constantly jet-setting around the world
but missing her friends
she finds it difficult to be around the
old gang again after her ex-husband gets
back to his womanizing ways
she continues her close relationship
with lily and eventually finds her way
back into the fray
not only does she go to ted and tracy's
wedding but she makes peace with barney
by 2030 robin is anchored in new york
once again
in the final scene ted shows up at her
door to win her back with the blessing
of his talked out teens
she finally gets everything she ever
wanted yes
clumsily shoving robin and ted together
at the end of the series which indicates
that
robin a smart and strong woman was
pining for ted this entire
time is just insulting to the amazing
character the showrunners built along
the way
no matter how tumultuous her life had
been the robin that emerges from season
9 would not have settled for ted
throughout the show two characters hold
an incredible amount of importance but
almost never say a word ted's future
children
penny and luke mosby for what feels like
years penny and luke sit
patiently and listen to their father's
wildly rambling story which takes plenty
of tangents and detours along the way
before he actually gets to the part
about how he met their mother
penny and luke get to reveal the show's
final twist and help their dad move on
with his life in the aftermath of their
mother's death
the point of the story is that is that
you totally totally totally have the
hots for aunt robin
not only was that twist fairly unpopular
but it was the only time in the show the
kids had an actual say in the story
aside from robin one of ted's
girlfriends always loomed large over the
series
victoria the impossibly adorable baker
ted meets at a wedding during the show's
first
season though the two immediately strike
up a relationship
everything is put on pause when victoria
gets the opportunity to move to germany
for work
and while she's away ted cheats on her
with robin ending the relationship for
the first time
during the seventh season victoria
reappears but makes it clear to ted that
his continued involvement with robin and
barney despite the trio's awkward
combination of romantic entanglements
is just too weird however at the end of
that season
ted and victoria reconnect on the day of
her wedding and she leaves her boyfriend
for him
restarting their relationship once again
in the end
ten and victoria aren't meant to be and
victoria returns to germany after she
presents ted with an ultimatum that he
must stop talking to robin
and he refuses at least victoria got to
move abroad and keep living out her
culinary dreams
we'll call it a win there's no denying
that ted mosby gets one of the best
endings of
anybody on the show but considering how
difficult his character can be to handle
at times
this is ultimately a pretty frustrating
outcome in the end
ted gets everything he wanted and then
some despite the fact that he shows
himself to be selfish
self-righteous and entirely overbearing
toward the women in his life
nice guys really do finish last and
emotionally manipulative soft boys
sometimes not to win after striking up a
perfect yet doomed relationship with
tracy
ted seems entirely settled as a single
dad and it seems as if he's put his
idealistic
stop at nothing romantic attitude in the
rear view mirror
however after his kids encourage him to
resume his quest for robin
agreeing ted is back to his old tricks
standing outside of robin's window and
triumphantly holding up the blue french
horn he stole for her way back in the
first season
ted may be the show's main character but
he can also be its most grating so to
see him get both a perfect marriage and
the woman of his dreams
feels slightly unearned out of
everyone on how i met your mother few
characters deserved a perfect
ending as much as lily the kind sweet
glue that holds the entire gang together
time and time again lily always looks
out for her friends and loves her
husband and baby son marvin but after
spending years as a kindergarten teacher
she finds herself yearning for greater
professional achievement
later in life luckily lily gets offered
the job of her dreams as an art
consultant but
unluckily it requires moving to italy
which causes friction between her and
marshall
when push comes to shove lily and
marshall along with marvin and their
newborn daughter daisy
do spend a year in italy which doesn't
prevent marshall from pursuing his
dreams
either later they have a second daughter
after years of helping others from her
students to her friends
lily finally gets to live her best life
in italy as a professional art
consultant
a dream years in the making far and away
the sweetest character on the show
marshall erickson is defined by three
things his love for lily his devotion to
his friends
and his quest to save the world from
certain doom as an environmental lawyer
marshall's ambitions finally pay off
when during the show's ninth and final
season
his application to become a judge is
approved and he has offered a recently
vacated seat on the bench this incites a
rift between marshall and lily however
as he doesn't immediately tell her that
their move to italy conflicts with his
opportunity to become a new york judge
in the end when marshall finds out lily
is pregnant with daisy
he immediately agrees to follow her to
italy and continues working in corporate
law until another seat on the bench
opens up for him happily one does upon
their return to new york and marshall is
ultimately elected to the new york state
supreme court in 2020 fulfilling his
dreams of helping the world the only
recurring character on how i met your
mother to appear in all of the show's
nine seasons
driver ranjit singh is present for
nearly every significant moment in each
main character's life this also means
ranjit is present for a lot of the
gang's immature nonsense
including plenty of fights and squabbles
and even a bizarre subplot where lily
inadvertently reveals that she had a sex
dream about ranchite much to marshall's
shock and disgust after years of driving
what appears to be the same five people
around new york city
and the surrounding area future ted
reveals in season 9 that ranjit
ultimately starts an incredibly
successful limousine group and gets rich
that's great because no one on this show
deserves happiness more than ranjit
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one